sur la ligne de front au nord de kharkiv
un char ukrainien cachés dans une forêt
non filmant mais cette position doit
rester secrète ces soldats sont des
tankistes dans leurs mains
les projectiles à destination des aînés
ruraux
après six mois de guerre le jeune
commandant reconnaît que malgré leurs
efforts le front se fige pas d'avancée
pas de recul la guerre d'usure
s'installe la jupette on utilise des
drones pour débusquer les positions des
russes quand elles sont repérées on sort
nos chars on se rapproche on cherche une
position abriter et on dire jusqu'au
petit nul ce qu aurait paniqué voici
donc le quotidien de ces tankiste pas d'
attaque de grande envergure mais un
harcèlement de l'ennemi le commandant a
29 ans soldat sous ses ordres en a 21
départ ce matin pour aller cibler une
station radar russe simple à moins de 5
km
que dieu vous protège dit le commandant
le jeune soldat de 21 ans est en route
vers sa cible
il ya six mois avant la guerre il
conduisait un tracteur dans la ferme de
ses parents le voici ce matin lors de la
tacc il se filme pour publier ces images
sur les réseaux sociaux
maintenant
il sourit après avoir tiré mais au
retour il raconte c'est peur
quand je me rase chaque fois que je vais
au combat je me demande si je vais
mourir
je sais que c'est la vraie guerre j'en
ai conscience je peux très bien ne pas
revenir
long silence et émotion d'un jeune homme
qui envoie systématiquement un sms à ses
parents avant de combattre
sur cette deuxième position d'autres
dentiste tout aussi jeune à 28 23 ans
déjà qu d'antan de leur unité il dirige
des soldats beaucoup plus à jeter mais
la hausse derrière les militaires les
failles mendois se donne moi j'avais
cinq qu'on a mis soldats de mon âge et
aujourd'hui seulement deux sont encore
vivants je n'arrive pas je ne peux pas
vous expliquer cette émotion que je
ressens avec tout ça le ces moitiés je
vous assure que je ne pense plus à ma
vie mais c'est mon écrit là je me dis
qu'est-ce que je donne les bons heures
est-ce que je les commande bien je
prenais ce que je saurai les protéger
stupéfiante responsabilité à seulement
22 ans en six mois de guerre 9000
soldats se craignent un sont morts au
combat selon les autorités militaires du
pays au plus fort des combats en juin
l'armée ukrainienne perdait jusqu'à 250
soldats par jour aujourd'hui les pertes
sont moins importantes 20 à 30 hommes
par jour cela s'explique aussi par le
fait que ces fronts sont désormais figée